I've had trouble accepting what he saw
for Luke but again I mean I have to say
having seen the movie I was wrong
[Music]
I've seen this raw strength only once
before it didn't scare me enough time
it doesn't know the biggest writing
challenge from me was Luke Skywalker you
know because he as you can see from the
poster he looms large over this movie I
think the world of Rian Johnson I said
to him I totally disagree with what you
think about Luke figuring out where it
where does it make sense for his head to
be at figuring out what part he was
gonna play in this film that for me was
kind of the big gorilla of this movie
who says it's time for the Jedi to end
huh
once I crack to that then I felt like
okay I think now we have now we can get
into it and tell our story how could
this happen what could have happened to
this guy that he would wind up the most
hopeful optimistic guy now this bitter
old cynic this is the chapter where
we're gonna challenge all these
characters we have to really push them
to extremes and that means that actors
are gonna be asked quite a lot I think
being pushed out of your comfort zone is
a good thing because if I were just
another benevolent Jedi training young
Padawans
we've seen it and nobody can do it
better than now I can it's and I we
shouldn't even try it's not the Luke
from the original trilogy it's a loop
from the new generation hey everybody
happy holidays so we got to break down
all this Luke stuff it's just awesome to
watch Mark Hamill reacting to everything
in all these interviews that have been
posting recently so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the movie
yet double bonus - there's extra
giveaway stuff at the end of the video
so be sure to subscribe if you're just
finding me for the first time it's funny
watching all these interviews with Mark
Hamill and you sort of see the journey
that he went on with the Luke Skywalker
character in the new trilogy as he was
experiencing all this stuff for the
first time the way we experienced it in
the movie theater like he comes in going
okay you know Luke Skywalker's been on
this journey in the past films before he
even invented a non canonical backstory
for himself between Episode six and
Episode seven the way that a lot of
actors do like even if you don't need
their backstory for what's happening
during the movie the actor needs to
understand why the characters doing what
they do so usually those are
conversations that they have during the
script phase like where they're talking
to the director like okay why is my
character on this island again why am I
not showing up to the very
episode seven so this is really
interesting journey with the way that
the films are treating the original
Trinity this video is mostly going to
focus on the Luke Skywalker character
but you can kind of see it with the
other members of the Trinity with Leia
and Han especially when they were going
through a couple different versions of
Episode seven so there's a lot of people
that are taking mark Hamill's comments
with the way he reacted to Luke
Skywalker in Episode eight and taking it
to mean that like he really is upset
with what's going on with the character
which isn't totally the case he was just
shocked
the way that a lot of people were
shocked in the movie theater like oh my
god what's going on why is he acting
like this how come he's not helping out
all the things that he said at the end
of that interview are the things that
went through all of your minds as you're
sitting in the movie theater if you're a
fan of a certain age you grew up with
the expanded universe novels so you got
Timothy Zahn's Thrawn Trilogy which was
sort of their version of episodes 7 8
and 9 then after that you get the jedi
academy trilogy the rise of the new Jedi
and the progeny of Leia and Han you have
Luke Skywalker that eventually gets
married tomorrow Jade they have a child
Ben Skywalker so was a fan of that
during Episode seven you're sitting in
the movie theater trying to draw these
parallels like oh very clearly they're
not doing EU anymore
but they are borrowing heavily from it
somatically with some of these character
traits but when we finally got the
explainer for Luke Skywalker in Episode
seven that he'd gone to this mysterious
Jedi Temple that was supposed to be the
first Jedi Temple we didn't know what he
was doing there it was just this JJ
Abrams mystery box item that future
filmmakers that were gonna handle
episodes 8 & 9 we're gonna have to deal
with because originally JJ Abrams wasn't
going to direct any of the other movies
in the new trilogy just episode 7
because he had a talent for
reinvigorating franchises and he's
mostly known for his mystery box
abilities asking really good questions
without necessarily having the answers
to those questions right away so a
couple of big problems that Rian Johnson
had when he was working on episode 8 and
the Luke Skywalker character in
particular is that JJ Abrams just handed
him this mystery box without any real
answers like hey you know just come up
with your own answers to the questions
that I asked and probably the other
biggest challenge is that he had to
start
writing episode eight just as they were
starting to film episode seven so he
didn't get to see any of the public
reaction to what was going on
during episode seven he said that while
he was riding he got to see dailies with
the actors so he didn't get to see the
final version of the film before he
wrote it but he did get to see what the
actors felt like together on screen so
already it feels like there's just a lot
of challenges when it comes to episode
AIDS so there are a lot of twists that
he either throws out literally like with
Luke Skywalker's lightsaber like he just
Chuck's it over his shoulder like oh you
know this thing that you thought was
super important they called out to you
through the force now it turns out that
this is just the MacGuffin this isn't
the important thing the important thing
that's going on is that we have to
reignite the legend of Luke Skywalker
but it's gonna take me the entire movie
to come to that conclusion so I think if
you're having a lot of WTF reaction to
the way that Luke Skywalker was treating
Rey during the course of Episode eight
the way he was kind of an just
telling her to get out the Jedi need to
end I don't want to have anything to do
with this you'll be better off without
me it's just him slowly coming to the
conclusion that they will literally be
better off without him as he becomes a
force ghost it is able to operate on a
much higher level in the narrative when
he's a force ghost than when he's just a
person who has to fly around normal
style like every other character so
that's why he had lines of dialogue like
you expect me with my laser sword to go
face down the entire first-order but as
a force ghost he can actually do things
like that although it doesn't go down
quite the way you'd expect like he
actually does face down the entire first
order with his laser sword as he calls
it that was a bit of a weird joke in the
film but he defeats them by doing
nothing like it's almost the more
powerful action like he defeats them by
causing a distraction it winds up being
this big twist on the earlier
conversation with Rey I think people
were mostly upset with the idea that it
took Luke this long to come to that
conclusion like if he's been on this
island meditating in exile then wouldn't
he have figured out that he could
influence things more as a force ghost a
long time ago like what has he been
doing this whole time aside from
drinking all that green milk so if
you're really upset by a lot of that
stuff I feel like a lot of the blame
lies in the mechanics of blockbuster
films and how big twists worked like
this
very much a big blockbuster film even
though it's a Star Wars film and the way
that JJ Abrams set up a bunch of really
interesting questions without any ideas
for what the answers would be
particularly supreme leader snoke Ray's
parents in like I said Anakin
Skywalker's lightsaber like why was the
lightsaber calling to her why didn't
they address that at all during Episode
eight again all JJ Abrams stuff not Ryan
Johnson's stuff but here's the thing
because JJ Abrams is now coming back to
do episode 9 and he's writing that
script with Chris Terrio right now
they've already pitched a version of the
movie to the Disney CEO and Kathleen
Kennedy so they do have what you would
call a rough draft of the film that will
probably change before they start
filming episode 9 next year I think it's
supposed to start filming around the
summer but the whole idea is is that
based on the way that fans have reacted
to episode 8 it'll be interesting to see
if mr. fanservice JJ Abrams tries to do
a more fanservice sea version of episode
9 than you would have done otherwise but
let me know in the comments given all
the stuff that they set up during
episode 7 where the characters are in
episode 8 and all like the really crazy
twist how do you want them to bookend
this trilogy
like would you be happier with a more
fanservice e ending or do you want them
to push the envelope and do something
totally unexpected that you never
thought that they would try to do
what'll happen is is I do have a couple
more episode 9 videos and obviously
there's some big plot points to cover
like what's going on with obi-wan Kenobi
during the course of episode 8 but the
Han Solo trailer is supposed to drop
sometime before the Superbowl which is
at the beginning of February so just
leave all your video requests in the
comments below there'll be a couple of
other bonus videos during the Christmas
holiday and then the video schedule will
probably be back to normal by the 26th
of the 27th there's a new round of that
imax ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner for my last video Genesius
studios please private message me so I
can get your contact details click here
for all my last Jedi Easter eggs and
click here for brand new infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
happy holidays